el líder de la defensa civil Siria más
conocida como cascos blancos aseguró que
desde los terremotos del lunes Naciones
Unidas no ha enviado ayuda a la región
también desmintió una afirmación del
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez quien afirmaba que seis
convoyes de ayuda habían sido enviados
pero Los cascos blancos aseguran que
estos camiones ya habían salido antes
del terremoto y que la ONU realmente no
ha desplegado un plan de respuesta para
los damnificados tras la catástrofe
Permíteme describirles la situación de
manera honesta la situación en Siria
ahora es catastrófica si quisiéramos
hablar sobre el papel de la ONU podemos
decir que es catastrófico la ONU debería
disculparse con el pueblo sirio la
oficina de Naciones Unidas para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios que
normalmente se encarga de la respuesta a
este tipo de catástrofes no ha
respondido hasta el momento a las
críticas sin embargo la organización
internacional para las migraciones
asociada a la ONU informó que vehículos
con ayuda llegaron a terreno
puedo confirmar que a las 10 en punto de
esta mañana hora local Se enviaron 14
camiones adicionales con humanitaria
muy necesaria al noreste Siria para
ayudar a unas mil cien familias en esta
zona devastada por el terremoto en live
con algunos artículos de Socorro
esenciales
Los cascos blancos también denuncian que
no han llegado a equipos humanos que les
ayuden en las tareas de búsqueda de
rescate salvo un equipo de rescate
egipcio Y otro español el acceso a la
zona es difícil ya que solo existe un
paso fronterizo que conecta Siria con
Turquía hasta el momento los civiles de
Los cascos blancos han estado a cargo
prácticamente solos de las tareas de
búsqueda de rescate han salvado la vida
a muchas personas enterradas y rescatado
víctimas fatales Mientras tanto muchos
otros siguen desaparecidos